-Making his TV debut,
performing "Issues"
from his new album,
"The Melodic Blue,"
give it up for Baby Keem!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Up-tempo music plays ]
♪♪
-♪ I been duckin' my friend ♪
♪ I been stuck on my ends ♪
♪ Memories about people ♪
♪ All in my head ♪
♪ First come to mind
is my mama ♪
♪ Buyin' me Jordans ♪
♪ Are we really made equal? ♪
♪ 'Cause everybody got plans ♪
♪ I can't go ghost ♪
♪ I face demons ♪
♪ Don't let it defeat you ♪
♪ I'll win my ends ♪
♪ I know it's hard for you ♪
♪ Takin' out the trends ♪
♪ I look myself in the mirror
when i can ♪
♪ Let's speak the truth ♪
♪ Tell me in pieces ♪
♪ I know it's you ♪
♪ I know just what you do ♪
♪ I know since we first got
evicted on a roof ♪
♪ I know, since rehab,
I was just tryna see you ♪
♪ How can I resent you? ♪
♪ Demons and tissue ♪
♪ Grandma and I missed you ♪
♪ You don't know
what we been through ♪
♪ Let the wolves come get you ♪
♪ Please don't let 'em
come get you ♪
♪ How could I resent you? ♪
♪ Demons and tissue ♪
♪ Grandma and I miss you ♪
♪ You don't know
what we been through ♪
♪ Don't let the wolves
come get you ♪
♪ Please don't let 'em
♪♪
♪ Run away from home,
run away from home ♪
♪ In a nice home,
in a nice home ♪
♪ Run away from home,
run away from home ♪
♪ Home, home ♪
♪ Why, oh, why, oh, why, oh,
I don't seem to be convinced? ♪
I don't question my exit? ♪
♪ Why, oh, why, oh, why, oh,
why, oh, livin' on a fence? ♪
why, oh, sleepin' away? ♪
♪ Why, oh, why, oh, why, oh,
why, oh, get me so upset? ♪
why, oh, any day? ♪
♪ Why you listen
to the demons in your head? ♪
♪ Why do we play victim? ♪
♪ Good times are ahead ♪
♪ Attention,
this is my life sentence ♪
♪ Hunh, hunh ♪
♪ You're committed ♪
♪ Offense about your vision,
hunh ♪
♪ Don't you get offended, huh? ♪
♪ When the darkness hits ♪
♪ I'll show you all
that I'm not kiddin', hunh ♪
♪ Grow a tree,
plant these seeds ♪
♪ Let it breathe,
my sister, Ree-Ree ♪
♪ Only see me on a screen ♪
♪ I know she needs me ♪
♪ I can help but feel, T ♪
♪♪
♪ How can I resent you? ♪
♪ Demons and tissue ♪
♪ Grandma and I missed you ♪
♪ You don't know
what we been through ♪
♪ Don't let the wolves
come get you ♪
♪ Please don't let 'em
♪ How can I resent you? ♪
♪ Demons and tissue ♪
♪ Grandma and I miss you ♪
♪ You don't know
what we been through ♪
♪ Don't let the wolves
come get you ♪
♪ Please don't let 'em
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]